I can see how the however many women six
seven eight nine women would all have
their own quote network and friends and
family and then going to this small town
and people become very invested in yeah
you and your project let's take a
filmmaker that lives in a big city yeah
and they're starting from scratch and
they've got this great idea and they're
gonna launch a Twitter and it's gonna be
about the film yeah what are they
treating about because the film hasn't
even been made yet so the cool thing
about what we call message testing which
is kind of building the relationship
with your audience and learning how they
like to be spoken to is that you can
start with all of the stuff that you do
anyway you're reading articles for
inspiration you're doing research you're
finding photos you're finding reference
materials and you can start to and
you're also looking I mean certainly in
documentary you're like looking for
people to talk to as part of your
research in in narrative you might be
going out and researching certain
situations or cutting you know I don't
know going to a coffee shop and watching
people or whatever
I think dear white people is a great
example Justin wanted to learn about the
voice of this main character and how
people would react to this voice of this
radio disc jockey who who has a show
called dear white people so he started
the dear white people Twitter handle and
he started tweeting things that he
thought she might say and that helped
actually structure his screenplay right
and so it was part of his own internal
research that he was externalizing and
people I mean it was a huge it was a
sensation right and so I think you take
the things that are already happening as
a part of your world of inspiration and
you are sharing it with the community
and you're asking people about it you
might be asking specific people this is
the beauty of Twitter is you can kind of
get to anyone and you can go out and ask
specific people specific questions along
the way and you see filmmakers who are
really good at building audiences and
burns while he's writing he's
communicating with his Twitter followers
like what should I name this character
and you're getting people invested
the storytelling all along it always
starts with your own personal network
and I have to be honest if you're going
to be an independent filmmaker you
better be a nice helpful collaborative
person you have to build your social
capital to live in this world it's very
very difficult to make an independent
film entirely by yourself and generally
speaking the best ones come from really
awesome bold collaborations at least
that has been my experience so the way
that you are in the world is part of
this go out and meet people at places
talk about the things that you're doing
and the things that you're thinking
about volunteer on a couple of your
friends sets build some relationships
offer to do social media on your own
your friends set so you're helping them
build their audience altruism is a
tremendous way to build a following if
you just started a Twitter account that
was entirely dedicated to recommending
films that you thought were really
excellent to people you thought might
really like them you will immediately
gather a following and that might be
something you like to do authenticity is
a really important piece of this if
you're not a smiley face happy
exclamation point a person don't be that
person on social media because you'll
hate yourself and you'll stop doing it
right
find your niche my friend Caitlyn was
saying the other day you know Twitter
just doesn't do it for her she can't
quite that's not she's not she is a
wordsmith actually she's a brilliant
writer but not in 140 characters she
feels very limited but she loves taking
photographs so Instagram has been the
place where she's really like found her
kind of social media tone and she feels
comfortable with that level of
interaction and she learns a lot about
what people like and don't like along
the way and that I know effects her as
an artist as she develops you know her
next script did that answer your
question it did we threw the name Ed
Burns in there which I think gets put in
all the time and that's nothing against
him
well film I think it's and everybody's
at burns you know sure that I think it's
important to look at people who are good
at it and you can't point out it there
are lots of famous people who do not
have a rabid following like Ed Burns and
that the difference is Ed Burns is good
at Twitter and they are not there are
plenty of famous people who have
attempted and failed at crowdfunding
because they don't understand that they
have to have a relationship with their
audience that matters Spike Lee's
campaign almost did not succeed at first
because his initial crowdfunding pitch
was lousy and ignored what it would take
to get his fans who had been interacting
with for a long time to convert to
crowdfunding supporters he didn't
understand what it took he altered his
pitch video partly through his campaign
and that's when it really stepped up and
succeeded right he got schooled by his
fans on crowdfunding right and I think
that's really important is that the
crowd is going to make you a more
attented attentive empathic artist
ultimately because you're expanding the
empathic space for inspiration you know
you never know what tweet might come at
you what offer might come to you that
will change the course of your script
maybe for like the water anyway it was
these spaces that were new ways to
describe our story that we rewrote the
script to accommodate and so if you
don't like the Ed Burns example then I
will go back to the Justin Simien dear
white people example he was not famous
to start he just had a really funny
engaging Twitter account that was based
on him wanting to inspire himself right
and seeking inspiration from the
audience I'll tell you what I hate it
when I have to have the conversation
with filmmakers or artists in general
who were like but that's pandering to
the audience and the problem that I have
with that statement on its face is that
if you think you can pander to an
audience
means you think your audience is stupid
and the logical extension of that is if
your audience is stupid then your movies
are stupid right
stupid audiences would like a stupid
movie right so I think it behooves us
all to assume that our audiences the
ones that were seeking the ones that
were building the ones that were
interacted interacting with are at least
as smart as we think we are
you